dot is working to fix the 95 near
downtown las vegas
and this project will take some time
that's where joe moeller joins us live
joe what does this mean for our commute
well it means a bit of a headache well
this project got started this weekend
will go on for the next
year and a half take a live look at the
southbound lanes of the 95 you can see
the backup
is starting this is where the lane
closures actually start where these
freeways merge you can see
even on the flyover ramps there's a back
up there this morning and throughout the
day there has been lingering
traffic from the 15 to the 95 south this
is a 40 million dollar repair project
crews will repave and add a lane to one
side
both directions of the 95 and 515 will
be down to two lanes between the
spaghetti bowl and eastern this is
supposed to go on through december of
2022.
earlier today we spoke to john who lives
nearby he says
one day he was already on day one he was
already stuck in this traffic
i will avoid it at all costs now that i
see just firsthand
just yesterday what i see and it hasn't
really even started yet
i'll avoid it with all costs
the southbound lane work already started
tonight the northbound lane changes will
begin
the southbound casino center exit
downtown will be closed through
september
there will be more closures as well
throughout the duration of the project
now back out here live if this is one of
your routes you are suggested to
maybe find an alternate route you're
taking a live look at the closed exit
sign there that is casino center but
again there will be more closures on
different exits throughout the duration
of the project you can also get updates
sent straight to your phone we have a
link to do so
on that on our website eightnessnow.com
reporting live near downtown las vegas
joe mohler 8 news now